In terms of the four laws of thermodynamics,
I think to a particle physicist actually the
conservation of energy
is the most important one.
If energy wasn't conserved, we'd have no predictive
power whatsoever.
To actually come up with equations of motion
which describe a system...
any system, I'm talking throwing a ball through
the air, a pendulum, a car rolling down the
street...
You have to assume that certain quantities
are conserved.
The wonderful thing is we can build up from
such a basic concept like that,
something as simple as saying 'energy is conserved:
Energy in, energy out',
In a particle physics collision when we take
two beams,
collide them together, mess happens and everything
flies out
and we've created all these new particles,
some of those particles we can't detect in
the particle detectors,
so things like neutrinos, for example, they
have almost zero mass.
They really don't interact much.
And so when we add up all the pieces of collision
and say
"OK, did this collision stat with Higgs boson
and then decay to these other products?"
If we add up all the products of the collision
but one is missing,
then we go if we know that energy is conserved,
then we can check what that missing product
was.
it's actually a method that's used in particle
physics analysis is to use this missing momentum
method
and if you know the decay you're looking for,
then you can say,
"Ok I've measured these three things, and
those two things,
I've got a missing momentum which corresponds
to my neurtrino,
You can infer where it came from.
If energy wasn't conserved the answer would
be different every time.
We'd have no predictive power whatsoever of
how things work in the world.